For in these times when banking does not lend
and therefore breaks with its main function,
what we see is that it accumulates record profits,
26.4 billion euros
in the year 23 and does not do it to lend money,
as he said,
but to charge people more
through the curtains
and for paying less
to people through interests in the accounts,
in your checking accounts or deposits.
And that at the same time impoverishes the services it provides.
More than half of the bank offices
that existed before
of 2 008,
They have disappeared
with the jobs that existed
and with attention
to the people who needed their services.
They also have more millions,
but have fewer employees.
They have more millions but have fewer offices.
They have more millions but offer fewer services.
Where is the social work?